[Applaus]
[Musik]
wie ich euch kenne liebe
visualpolitikzuschauer habt ihr diese
Meldung auch mitbekommen davor im August
dieses Jahres ein chinesisches Schiff
nach Sri Lanka und es konnte dort auch
anlegen zumindest nach einigem Hin und
Her das Hin und Her hatte mit Indien zu
tun denn für Neu-Delhi war dieses Schiff
ein spionageschiff dass sie nicht so
gerne vor ihre Küste sehen wollten da
konnte ich ihnen noch so oft behaupten
es sei nur ein harmloses
Forschungsschiff gewesen das alles macht
uns von visualpolitik natürlich ein
wenig neugierig was ist denn für China
so interessant an Sri Lanka es handelt
sich bei der Insel ja nicht gerade um
eine Perle von einer Volkswirtschaft im
Gegenteil das Land befindet sich in
einer brutalen Krise Sri Lanka ist
pleite und die Regale in den Läden sind
leer und fünf von sechs Haushalten fehlt
es an notwendigen Lebensmittel mehr noch
etwa 5 Millionen Menschen leiden an
Unternehmen Nahrungsmangel das ist fast
jeder vierte von den rund 22 Millionen
Einwohnern auch Treibstoff ist knapp die
Menschen stehen ständig Schlange
entweder nach Essen oder um zu tanken
Gas zum Kochen ist genau genauso wie
Strom der teilweise einen halben Tag
gleich ausfällt und die Geschäft und
jegliche Produktion lahm legt Schulen
und Behörden geht das Papier aus
Krankenhäuser die Medikamente und
niemand kann behaupten man hatte es
nicht kommen sehen was ich gerade in Sri
Lanka abspielt ist eine Krise mit Ansage
aber was haben in dieser ganzen
Situation die in der Gegend die
chinesischen Forscher auf ihrem
Forschungsschiff nur nach indischer
Lebensart wollen die Chinesen mit der
Johann Wang 5 so der Name des Schiffes
nichts anderes als spionieren und zwar
indische Militäreinrichtungen
ausspionieren die sich in der Nähe Sri
Lankas befinden zudem ist das Schiff
ausgerüstet mit riesigen Antennen und
Abhöranlagen die zum Beispiel Satelliten
überwachen und auch die Flugbahnen von
intercontinentalraketen tracken können
Indien ist aufs höchste alarmiert wenn
sich China in einer Gegend breit macht
welche die Inder als ihre eigene
Einflusszone betrachten und das
Beunruhigende ist dass die derzeitige
Wirtschaftskrise in Sri Lanka einen
Vorteil für die Chinesen und ihren
militärischen expansionswellen darstellt
wie das alles genau zusammenhängt
erklären wir euch deswegen in diesem
Video zunächst müssen wir aber verstehen
wie Sri Lanka in diesen Schlamassel
geraten konnte nun es fängt an mit einer
schlechten Regierung und führt zu
Schulden bei einem üblen Gläubiger aber
eines nach dem anderen wie so oft werden
wir uns zusammen wir durch einen kurzen
Blick in die Geschichte Sri Lankas
herleiten zuvor möchte ich euch jedoch
auf unseren neuen Kanal visual
economic.de hinweisen der schon morgen
mit seinem ersten Video Premiere feiern
wird falls ihr diese nicht verpassen
wollt könnt ihr ihn jetzt schon
abonnieren und euch auch für die
Premiere anmelden wir freuen uns schon
riesig darauf
Freund und wir uns auch über jede Spende
von euch mit uns hält dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen und wie ihr seht sogar zu
erweitern den Spenden Link über Paypal
findet ihr in der Beschreibung unter
diesem Video und er funktioniert auch
wenn ihr selbst über kein eigenes PayPal
Konto verfügt und zwar viele von euch
uns diese Frage stellen payPal bietet
uns derzeit wirklich die günstigste
Kostenstruktur viel günstiger als
Youtube Mitgliedschaften oder patreon
das heißt über Paypal kommt das meiste
von eurem Geld auch bei uns an also
macht uns doch eine kleine Freude und
hält uns gleichzeitig dabei euch noch
mehr interessante Videos zu liefern ich
danke Euch so und nun schnell hinein in
die bewegte Geschichte Sri Lankas
der sugar der die dessertscha paxaclans
in den vergangenen 20 Jahren herrschte
in Sri Lanka vor allem ein Clan die
Familie Radja paxa ihr Oberhaupt
Behinderter durchlief ein politisches
Amt nach dem anderen in dem Land er war
Parlamentarier Minister
Oppositionsführer und Premierminister
und 2005 gebannt er schließlich die Wahl
zum Präsidenten von Sri Lanka damals
herrschte in dem Land schon seit rund 20
Jahren Bürgerkrieg hier kämpften die
Regierungstruppen des Landes gegen eines
aparatisten Bewegung die Termine in
seinem Amt angekommen begann Roger paxa
mit Hilfe des Militärs eine brutale
Offensive gegen die Familien die
Regierung hatte dafür einen mächtigen
Unterstützer auf ihrer Seite China 2009
siegte die Armee über die Separatisten
und das bedeutet viel Zuspruch und
Popularität für die aus nicht nur
Präsident mach hinter selbst profitierte
davon sondern auch sein Bruder brutal
bayerischer paxa damals
Verteidigungsminister und bekannt für
seinen Kanal harten Führungsstil wir
werden im Laufe dieses Videos noch viel
von ihm hören 2010 standen
Präsidentenwahlen an und die
Popularitätswelle trugmahinder Pax zum
Sieg auch bei den Parlamentswahlen im
selben Jahr triumphierte paxa aus Partei
die Opposition hat er nicht den Hauch
einer Chance es sei aber auch erwähnt
dass deren Anführer General sterest von
seeker wegen angeblicher Verschwörung
verhaftet wurde und die Opposition damit
führungslos zur Wahl antreibt beide
Wahlen waren von gewalttätigen
Ausschreitungen begleitet sowie
Verhaftungen und entsprechend
berichteten Ball Beobachter von
erheblichen Unregelmäßigkeiten kurzum
man sollte sich die Wahlen in Sri Lanka
nicht so geordnet und regelmäßig
vorstellen wie zum Beispiel in
Deutschland mit Ausnahme Berlins und
ähnlich untergemäßig oder
unübersichtlich muss man sich auch
vorstellen wie es beim Wiederaufbau des
Landes zugeht tja und an dieser Stelle
kommt wieder China ins Spiel das rote
Riesenreich und sich und seine Yuan als
Hilfe beim Wiederaufbau an wie wir sehen
werden nicht ohne eine ordentliche
Gegenleistung zu verlangen auf jeden
Fall sahen die Brüder jetzt ihre große
Chance bekommen alle ihre Träume wahr
werden zu lassen und wir reden hier
nicht vom Häuschen im Grünen sondern
wunderschönen Dingen die Macht und
Reichtum eines Familienclans ausdrücken
mit anderen Worten alles was
großprächtig und teuer ist
so begann man 2012 mit dem Bau des
lotustowers in der Hauptstadt Colombo
mittlerweile fertiggestellt ist der
Funkturm mit 350 Metern eines der
höchsten Gebäude Südostasiens bezahlt
haben es die Chinesen der Turm kostete
mehr als 100 Millionen Dollar und wurde
von der chinesischen excel-bank der
Export Import Bank of China finanziert
china hat auch 8,5 Millionen Dollar
bereitgesteuert für den Bau des Milow
Kurkum
eine prächtige Bühne zum großen Rom des
Präsidenten in Sri Lankas aber auch ein
Flughafen bekam den berühmten Namen der
International Airport sollte jeden
Passagier die Großartigkeit der
Herrscherfamilie zeigen nur blieben die
Passagiere aus 2013 eingeweiht wurden
kaum 100 Passagiere pro Tag abgefertigt
und drei Jahre später erhielt er das
wenig schmeichelhafte Etikett leerster
Flughafen der Welt gekostet hatte
Geister Airport trotzdem über 200
Millionen Euro und wer hat auch das
finanziert China ja und damit wären wir
auch schon bei einem netten Konzept
internationaler Diplomatie die eine
frappierende Parallele zum Alltagsleben
hat die Sugar Daddy Diplomatie was macht
eine sugaradies nun ganz klassisch läuft
es so eine junge Dame kann sich das
Leben durchaus angenehmer machen wenn
sie es versteht ihre Reize gut
einzusetzen und einen reichen Gönner
findet den Sugar Daddy dieser finanziert
ihre verrücktesten Ideen und materiellen
Träume oder vielleicht auch ganz
bodenständig die Ausbildung der sugar
der die verlangt aber eine Gegenleistung
schließlich hat er auch Bedürfnisse ihr
wisst was ich meine solche Verhältnisse
gibt es in vielen verschiedenen
Schattierungen von reizvoll über
konstruktiv bis tragisch von zwanglos
bis aus Blanca Not geboren und
wohlgemerkt es gibt auch sugar Mamis die
mit männlichen Gigolos in diesen
Tauschhandel der Bedürfnisse eintreten
die Konstellation sind in jeder Hinsicht
vielfältig und wenn sich zwei Länder
finden wo das eine etwas will und das
andere etwas geben kann natürlich gegen
Gegenleistung dann kann man das eben
Sugar Daddy Diplomatie nennen und ihr
ahnt sich ja schon wer im Kontext
unseres Videos der Sugar Daddy und wer
das Objekt der Begierde ist nun China
wurde zu Sri Lankas Sugar Daddy China
bezahlte was Sri Lankas Diktator haben
wollte aber das Luxusleben passt die
Bauten und das schöne Theater haben
seinen Preis china will eine
Gegenleistung
[Musik]
und an dieser Stelle kommt der Hafen von
hamban toter ins Spiel die Stadt kann
man total ist nicht gerade eine der
wichtigsten Städte in Sri Lanka sondern
liegt eher abgelegen in der weniger
entwickelten Südprovinz des Landes aber
zufälligerweise ist es genau die Gegend
aus der der Clan stammt und Raja paxa
wählte diesen Ort um den dortigen Hafen
zu einem großen tief wasserhafen
auszubauen China liest Sri Lanka haben
erst eine Milliarde Dollar für den
Ausbau des Hafens beide Länder
unterzeichneten 2017 dazu eine
Vereinbarung ein chinesischer
Staatsunternehmen die China Merchants
Group für den Hafen für 99 Jahre lang
lesen und damit den Betrieb übernehmen
85% der Gewinner des Hafens behält das
Unternehmen China ist gleich doppelt
interessiert an diesem Hafen einmal
kommerziell er könnte ein sehr wichtiger
Knotenpunkt werden auf der neuen
Seitenstraße schließlich ist er mitten
im Indischen Ozean gelegen ein anderes
Interesse jedoch ist militärischer Natur
wie ihr sicher wisst die böse Politik
Zuschauer sind Indien und Konkurrenten
auf der Weltbühne für Indien ist der
gesamte Indische Ozean indisches
Einflussgebiet das Land würde im
Konfliktfall auch versuchen den
Handelsverkehr nach China in der Region
zu blockieren diesen Hebel möchte Indien
nicht aus der Hand geben und besser noch
festlegen
[Musik]
die Verhältnisse würden sich jedoch
drastisch ändern sobald China einen
Militärhafen auf Sri Lanka hätte es wäre
so als hätte China eine
Militärstützpunkt in Indien oder
zumindest in indischen Einflussgebiet
und würde es denn Sri Lanka zulassen
dass die Chinesen einfach einen
Militärstützpunkt auf der Insel
errichten eigentlich ist das doch ein
Ding der Unmöglichkeit für ein Land das
ich immer neutral verhielt und auch
während des Kalten Krieges ein Teil der
Bewegung blockfreier starten war aber
die Schuldenfalle die der chinesische
sugar der die erzeugt hatte schnappte
eben zu und nun verlangt er seinen Preis
nicht einmal ein Machtwechsel in der
Regierung des Landes konnte die Dinge
grundsätzlich ändern und Sri Lanka aus
der Abhängigkeit von China befreien denn
2015 wurde jemand anders Präsident
Mystery Palace wir waren in jedem Jahr
die Wahl und in der Tat griff er den
scharf an das Land wäre von einer
Mafia-Familie kontrolliert und das drohe
eine Diktatur mit zügelloser Korruption
und Vetternwirtschaft tja aber all die
Wahrnehmungen nutzten nichts denn 19 kam
der Raja praxa-clan zurück und zwar
gewaltig seht her gott hat Bayern als
neuer Präsident Sri Lankas vereidigt
diesmal wurde gotta Beyer Präsident und
sein Bruder mal Hinderer paxa
Premierminister aber das ist noch nicht
alles seine anderen Brüder Basel und
Schamal übernahmen das Finanzministerium
und das Landwirtschaftsministerium
darüber hinaus wurden Gotthard Weyers
Neffen namal Minister für Jugend und
Sport und ein weiteres yoshita sogar
Staatschef der Armee diese Neffen sind
übrigens die Söhne des ehemaligen
Präsidenten mal Hinderer paxa na wenn
das kein Fall von family business ist
ich meine man glaubt es kaum trotz der
augenscheinigen Korruption und
Vetternwirtschaft setzen die Menschen in
Sri Lanka wieder einmal auf die Radja
paxas und in diesem Szenario ging ab
jetzt alles schief was nur schief gehen
konnte denn wie so oft kam auch auf Sri
Lanka nicht ein Unglück allein haltet
euch jetzt lieber
[Musik]
der Fall des Raja Packs Reiches
im Jahr 2019 erlebte das Land den
schlimmsten islamistischen Terrorangriff
seiner Geschichte
269 Tote bei mehreren gleichzeitigen
Anschlägen der Terror führte zu einem
starken Rückgang des Tourismus die
einreisen von Urlaubern nach Sri Lanka
gingen aufgrund der Angst vor weiteren
Einschlägen auf nur ein Sechstel zurück
im Monat vor dem Anschlag kamen noch zu
244.000 Touristen im Monat danach waren
es nur noch
88.000 das war natürlich ein Tiefschlag
für einen Wirtschaft die so abhängig ist
vom Tourismus und es kamen jetzt kaum
noch ausländische Devisen ins Land vor
dem Angriff brachte der Tourismus der
Insel jedes Jahr etwa 4 Milliarden
Dollar ein diese Einnahmen waren jetzt
futsch und dieser Rückgang der Einnahmen
viel mit einer Maßnahme der Regierung
zusammen die gar nicht so schlecht
klingt denn Gott hat bayerischer
packstar setzte eine Steuersenkung durch
die auf 2,2 Milliarden Dollar geschätzt
wird das Pech war nur dass diese
Steuersenkung zum absolut falschen
Zeitpunkt kam der nur kurz danach folgte
Corona eine Epidemie traf nun auf ein
Land mit einer Staatskasse die nur ganz
wenig Einnahmen hatte
[Musik]
umso größer war der corona-shop für Sri
Lanka lockdown-maßnahmen legten die
Wirtschaft lang und nachdem die
Touristen wegen des Terrors ausgeblieben
waren blieben sie nun wegen Corona Weg
die Einnahmen aus dem tourismusanken von
4,38 Milliarden Dollar im Jahr 2018 auch
nur noch 500 Millionen nach zwei Jahren
Pandemie vor diesem Hintergrund stuften
die großen Agenturen die
Kreditwürdigkeit Sri Lankas auf
absolutesniveau herab das machte eine
Kreditaufnahme auf den globalen
Kapitalmärkten für die ohnehin schon
hoch verschuldete regierungsrelancas
praktisch und möglich an diesem Punkt
sucht die Praxis einen Ausweg aus der
Sackgasse und zwar so wie ist die Praxis
gerne tun als Familie also sprach der
Präsident mit dem Russia Pack SAP
Premierminister und sie riefen den
Finanzminister an um ihm zu sagen hör zu
Bruder wie viel Geld haben wir noch in
der Zentralbank etwa 9 Milliarden Dollar
in Fremdwährung das ist genug also lasst
uns an diesen Vorrat gehen um die Löcher
zu stopfen aber es waren einfach zu
viele Löcher und die Regierung kam mit
ihrem stopfen nicht hinterher
[Musik]
der Anstieg der Rohstoffpreise drückte
die Gewinnmargen der Unternehmer zum
Beispiel beim Dünger was die Erträge in
der Landwirtschaft minderte aber auch
beim Öl im Jahr 2021 schließlich konnte
das Land einen Teil seiner Ölimporte
nicht mehr bezahlen man hat sich dann
mit dieser unkonventionellen Maßnahme
aus
Iran stimmt zu Tee aus Sri Lanka zu
nehmen um
251 Millionen Dollar ölschulden zu
begleichen aber was geschah mit den 9
Milliarden Dollar an Reserven nun die
schmolzen einfach der Himmel natürlich
versuchte man Schulden zu begleichen und
den Wert der Hobby irgendwie zu halten
aber nichts Halt im Jahr 2022 war die
Kasse leer die Regierung kündigte
daraufhin an dass sie die
Auslandsschulden in Höhe von 51
Milliarden Dollar nicht mehr zahlen kann
und den Schuldendienst aussetzen werden
die Rupie wertete daraufhin herabgede ab
und verläuft fast die Hälfte ihres
Wertes gegenüber den US-Dollar
[Musik]
die Importe wurden eingefroren mit
schrecklichen Folgen die Kosten für
alles im Land von Grundnahrungsmitteln
wie Reis Linsen Milchpulver und Zucker
bis hin zu Medikamenten schnellten in
die Höhe der Treibstoffmangel und die
Dürre führten zuständigen Stromausfällen
viel Unternehmen haben ihre Arbeit
eingestellt die Wirtschaft Sri Lankas
ist also durch einen hochgradig
gefährlichen Cocktail gelähmt hohe
Schulden eine schwache Währung Mangel an
allen möglichen Gütern und eine weitere
Zutat die derzeit in Überfluss vorhanden
ist Inflation die Inflation ist Sri
Lanka ist im Juli auf einen Rekordwert
von
60,8% gestiegen Präsident gotta
bayerischer paxa setzte die Armee ein um
seine Kritiker mit Gewalt zum Schweigen
zu bringen aber vergeblich und als in
diesem Sommer die Demonstranten sogar
die Häuser einiger Minister in Brand
setzen begann er die restlichen Praxis
zu entlassen um den Mob wenigstens ein
bisschen zu beruhigen aber so einfach
ließen sich die Menschen nicht mehr ab
Bremsen sich stürmten direkt den
Präsidentenpalast und guter bayerischer
praxa musste fliehen über die Malediven
ging es ins Exil nach Singapur von dort
erklärt er im Juli 2022 seinen Rücktritt
aber die Menschen Sri Lanka sind für
mindestens zwei Generationen im Voraus
ruiniert und die Frage ist wie kann Sri
Lanka aus dieser Krise aus dieser
absolut hoffnungslosen Situation
herauskommen nun das erklären wir euch
jetzt
[Musik]
die Rückkehr des sugar Daddys
etwa 45% der Schulden Sri Lankas werden
privaten Investoren geschuldet der Rest
entfällt auf verschiedene Länder und
multinationale Institutionen darunter
die Asiatische Entwicklungsbank mit 16 %
und Japan China und die Weltbank mit
jeweils zehn Prozent Sri Lanka muss
derzeit die Bedingungen für die Kredite
neu verhandeln und seine Gläubiger um
einen Schuldenerlass bitten und hier
wird die Lage für das Land noch
komplizierter Privatinvestoren sind
wahrscheinlich nicht bereit auch nur
einen Zentrum verlieren und einige wie
die Hamilton Reserve Bank haben sogar
rechtliche Schritte eingeleitet um ihre
Schulden einzutreiben und dann wäre da
noch China dass ich bereits geweigert
hat Sri Lankas Außenstände umzuschulden
seitdem sind die Verhandlungen diskreter
geworden bis zum August 22 als wir
wieder vom Hafen von hamban toter hörten
chinesisches Überwachungsschiff legt in
Sri Lanka an kann die johann-wang 5 zum
Ausspionieren Indiens genutzt werden nun
die Antwort ist ja das Schiff spioniert
beunruhigend ist auch dass ich offenbar
in den Beziehungen zwischen China und
Sri Lanka etwas geändert hat
[Applaus]
eigentlich wurde Hammer toter China für
99 Jahre unter der Bedingung überlassen
dass der Hafen nicht militärisch genutzt
wird dementsprechend wurde bereits 2017
ein chinesischen u-booti einfach in den
Hafen verweigert aber natürlich ist die
Position des srilankanischen Regierung
heute viel schwächer kann man seinem
sugar der die die Einfahrt in den Hafen
von hamban toter verweigern wenn man ihn
gleichzeitig anfliegt die Schulden zu
vergessen es ist klar das Sri Lanka
China alles geben wird was es verlangt
dein neuer Präsident Daniel beweist wo
die Prioritäten liegen sieht her wenn er
den Prime ist okay schon
dir gehen tja das hört man wohl gerne in
China Sri Lanka verhandelt derzeit mit
dem Internationalen Währungsfond über
ein Rettungspaket aber die neue
Regierung wird es nicht leicht haben im
Land sind Sparmaßnahmen sehr unpopulär
schließlich geht es um Steuererhöhungen
Kürzungen der öffentlichen Ausgaben
Privatisierungen die Menschen werden
verstehen sie jetzt ausbaden müssen aber
auch international dürfen die
Verhandlungen sehr hart es gibt ein
Rettungspaket ist IWF aber das ist an
Bedingungen gebunden unter anderem das
Sri Lanka sich mit seinen Gläubigen auch
eine Umschuldung also eine
schuldenerleichterung einigt dafür muss
das Land jedoch mit China in
Verhandlungen treten und wenn eines klar
ist dann dass China hier sehr hart
verhandeln wird
aber warum eigentlich wo liegt also das
Problem nun China ist nicht bereit einen
Präzedenzfall zu schaffen indem es bei
Schulden nachgibt vergesst nicht dass
China vielen wirklich sehr viel
Entwicklungsländern Geld geliehen hat
wenn alle diese Länder plötzlich
zahlungsunfähig würden wäre China in
sehr großen Schwierigkeiten mit anderen
Worten es gibt nur eine Sache die Sri
Lanka tun könnte um Chinas Herz zu
erreichen und das wäre den Hafen von
hamban toter für militärische Zwecke
abzutreten aber das würde bedeuten dass
Indien ein Militärstützpunkt seines
großen Konkurrenten direkt vor seiner
Haustür erdulden müsste das heißt ihr
könnt euch sicher vorstellen welches
Land Sri Lanka jetzt am meisten
unterstützt
Indien steht das Aussage seines
Außenministeriums an der Seite Sri
Lankas 3,8 Milliarden us-dollar-hilfe
für den Inselstaat in diesem Jahr Indien
als Retter in der Not nun der Sri
lankanische Präsident will von China weg
und sich Indien sehr stark annähern aber
ganz alleine wird der Nachbar im Norden
die Problem nicht lösen können die Lage
hier ist also noch völlig offen trotz
aller Betäubungen der regierungsrelanka
sich von China weg und mehr in Richtung
Indien zu orientieren wir werden auf
jeden Fall an der Sache dran bleiben
aber jetzt ist die Frage an euch
gerichtet meint ihr der Westen sollte
Sri Lanka helfen damit es sich aus
Chinas Schuldenfalle befreien kann
immerhin geht es ja nur um 5 Milliarden
Dollar ist eine Militärbasis der
Chinesen denn wirklich so eine Gefahr
während amerikanische Militärbasen den
Globus umspannen wie immer sind auf eure
anregende Diskussion zu diesem
interessanten Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
auch was dabei gelernt habt falls ja
geht nicht mit deinen likes Abo mit
Glöckchen keines unserer Videos mehr zu
verpassen natürlich freuen wir uns auch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch mit
uns hält dieses Projekt weiterzuführen
in PayPal Link dazu findet ihr wie
gesagt in der Beschreibung unter dem
Video mach's gut und bis bald
[Musik]